when you say I have a bull is it like
you own a horse in its in a field yeah
it's like owning a horse except it's a
bowl yeah that's all the time we have
unite everybody I think it was a gift
from my father-in-law when I married
when I married my wife he was like yeah
here you go here's a bull so I don't
know it was like a dowry thing or
something like that but we now have a
long horn bull named Big Tex wow did you
I think you brought a picture of big
time Big Tex yes I have to say I don't
know anything about bulls that looks
like a really good bull I know also very
little about poles and I think he's a
very good bull how do you now okay let's
find out obviously with a bull do you is
this a bull that you make money from
yeah you can start them so you take them
and they like he'll go and you know
breed with other cows right right yeah
okay so I have questions about that if
it's not indelicate sure is that it's
something where you just you put a cow
out there and you hope that they swipe
right or whatever and it works I'm
pretty sure that you just take them out
there and they turn before the Cowboys
say hey they're nothing
oh no oh so the Galliard what he meant
was it's not very romantic yeah yeah
very little romance yeah they make up
yeah yeah well I never seen it happen
okay all right and and what so because a
lot of money these bulls cost a lot of
money and when you're trying to breed
them just odd fee and all that yeah but
you got to join an organization like my
wife and I proud members of the Texas
longhorn Breeders Association right that
just sounds like you're swingers
[Laughter]
like right right yeah it's code it's
still a little too much breeding they so
that they actually the the the bull
mounts the cow and and it's there's as
they're uh yeah but I think there's also
like there's like a like a contraption
that you can kind of engage the bull
with and then that way cuz you know I
mean something go wrong if you just got
to big wild animals kind of go that an
animal could get hurt yeah like I've
heard a story like one cow kicked a bull
in his you said the F word so why not
just go for right yeah kicked a pulling
his balls and he lost his balls like so
now that Bulls done breed him right
right that's man okay it gets it gets so
there she can tell that now that Bulls
probably a couch so and you say there's
a what's the contraption I mean I don't
I've never handled it I've never really
gotten in there I accused you of nothing
I'm not defensive you're defensive
suddenly you're like I've never used to
guys
I mean it's it's I think it's about that
but yeah like a shake weight that you
just kind of like you know you go for it
it's a shape way
I've seen the shake weight marshal know
so you're a man well you're you just
pitched an idea I know someone's
watching at home right now who's gonna
say like wait a minute a way to exercise
you want to insulate poles and exercise
at the same time no I don't want to
inseminate the ball all right we're
talking about different things all oh
sorry sorry mother yeah I was talking
about a man wanting to have a
pleasurable moment why would a man want
to inseminate a bull and you inseminate
you're talking to a member of the
Breeders Association that's how you
that's a nice right yeah you inseminate
the cow not to em or just if you have
emanated bull you just make him feel
well I'm sorry dude we're not making a
lot of money okay sorry dude you came in
here with your salmon colored suit and
started saying all kinds of [ __ ] it's
late night talk show
oh boy this is one of those interviews
where I want to see a transcript later
on are the many different like how did
we get oh we're over here and then you
had a device strapped on yourself for
the holic article cey armies never allow
let's talk about cars yeah but I live do
that now we're gonna let's talk about
duster animated Disney movie no they're
so happy yeah such a good job fellas
yeah so anyway that's how the semen is
extracted from the bull disney/pixar you
know right now that stage there are
Disney people just on the phone you know
I mean they took very wrong
you